what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today
I will be breaking down the latest
massive developments in the black clover
story including the all-out attack by
the dark triad on the heart and lower
kingdoms the reveal of the demon mega
Cola and the introduction of the demon
king a demon who is potentially even
stronger than mega Cola and that's
saying a lot since McGee Cola has
already believed to be stronger than the
kotodama demon the black bulls are under
attack crazy stuff is happening all over
the place so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the black cover content right
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going please leave a like to let
me know it really does help and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you want to be notified
of our videos you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting the bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't you two blueberry our
videos and you might not see them at all
you can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar for all the
latest black clover news and updates
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers
we're talking about the latest
developments in the story were beyond
the animes so please proceed with
caution you have been warned the pivotal
chapter 240 starts off in the heart
kingdom with Charmy gorging herself on
food and beer girl talking about how
cute chunky Charmy is it's all fun and
games until beaver girl receives an
urgent message from the water spirit on
Dean on Dean shows Laura Pacheco mimosa
Noel and the others that there are six
different attacks going on inside the
heart Kingdom and what's more all of the
attackers were able to get through the
mana zone barrier easily and worse than
that it seems that all the attackers
have the power of a demon and they are
all zero stage mages the strongest type
of mage there is but one of the
attackers stands out from the rest and
that is none other than the dark triad
member Vanek a-- and at this point it is
revealed that wanaka is the one who is
possessed by the demon makey Kula Noel
is startled immediately as soon as she
hears that name because she knows that
Mikiko
was the demon who cursed her mother as
you will recall
according to Dorothea Unsworth Noelle's
mother died as a direct result of Meggie
khulus curse and of course we know that
Meggie claw is also the demon who cursed
Laura Pacheco for those who weren't sure
whether the Spade Kingdom's power comes
from one overpowered demon or multiple
separate demons this chapter seems to
confirm that there are indeed multiple
different demons involved and so McGee
Kula is only one of them
it appears that every member of the dark
triad is being possessed by a different
demon and presumably there are even more
demons who are possessing the other zero
stage mages from the Spade Kingdom but
how many demons are there and how is it
possible that so many different demons
have popped up inside the Spade Kingdom
up to this point demon sightings were
extremely rare for over 200 chapters we
only had Asta's demon and a kotodama
demon and of course the kotodama demon
had been sealed away for five hundred
years before eventually making his
glorious comeback so how do we go from
demons being an extremely rare and
unnatural sight to what looks like
dozens of different demons actively
conspiring with the Spade Kingdom in
order to take down the heart clover
Alliance there is definitely something
going on inside the spade Kingdom that
we are still not aware of there has to
be some explanation for why so many
demons have appeared inside the spade
Kingdom at this exact time and why they
seem to be actively helping the spade
army I am very curious to find out what
exactly is going on behind the scenes
and if you happen to have any ideas of
your own feel free to let me know the
focus of this chapter then shifts to an
area near the Spade border where the
black bulls are currently located inside
their mobile base Austin FINRA returned
from the battlefield and they greet
Vanessa gray and Ghosh it turns out that
Yami is away from the base he is
actually at a captain's conference
inside the clover Kingdom and fennel
and bring him back to the base Gordon is
off somewhere studying curse magic and
Henry is there but he is taking a nap
Charmy is also away still back inside
the heart Kingdom with Noel as we saw
earlier in the chapter and Zora and
Magna are gone too but then just as we
get the general idea of where all the
black bowls are colonel
located Henri snaps awake from his nap
he calls to the others immediately
because he can sense that someone is
here suddenly they realized that their
entire massive hideout is floating in
the air and it turns out that this is
the work of Dante of the dark triad
Dante has arrived and he uses gravity
magic this unique magic attribute is
what allows him to make the entire
mobile base float Dante says that since
it appears that Yami is away he'll have
to play with the rest of the black balls
while waiting for Yami to come back the
black bull's spring into action right
away and Henry uses recombination magic
to transform the mobile base into its
mecha form the black balls launch a mana
rocket punch at Dante but he uses an
interestingly named spell to basically
destroy the attack in seconds the name
of Dante's spell is gravity magic
presence of the demon king this is a
very interesting detail because we know
that Dante wears that big crown so it's
fair to assume that he is the leader of
the dark triad but thus calling his
spell presence of the demon king mean
that he is just Tooting his own horn as
the king of the spade kingdom or is this
referring to the demon that is
possessing him is it possible that
Dante's demon is the most powerful out
of all the demons the king of the demons
a demon who is even stronger than Meggie
kula Laura Pacheco has already confirmed
that Miggy kula is stronger than the
kotodama demon so if Dante has another
demon who is even stronger than Meggie
kula then the black balls are in really
big trouble the chapter ends as hasta
flies out on his flying surfboard sword
and challenges Dante to a direct fight
this is definitely in line with Oscars
character it's just who he is but
judging by what we've seen so far from
Dante and the dark triad in general I
would be extremely careful if I was
hasta these guys are not messing around
and if Dante really is the strongest of
the dark triad and if his demon power is
even stronger than the others then I
really don't think that also stands a
chance on his own as strong as hasta is
after
time-skip we saw what Zenon did to
William you know and the rest of the
Golden Dawn also after the time-skip
so assuming that Dante is even stronger
than Zenon I don't think that even a
post time-skip hasta can do anything by
himself here if the black bulls work
together as a team and use a lot of
strategy perhaps they can keep Dante
busy for long enough for Finn Rowlett to
come back with Yami
but that is a big if at this point all
in all this is building up to be a
really epic war arc but also potentially
very deadly one we saw what happened to
half of the Golden Dawn members and
while none of them were main characters
by any stretch of the imagination
my editor Dakota broski and I are both
extremely worried that one of the black
bulls might be killed by Dante before
Yami comes back it's definitely not
going to be hasta he is the main
character after all but I don't want to
lose any of the black bulls realtalk the
black bulls are one of my favorite
squads in the history of anime and I
really don't want to lose any of these
guys especially not the majestic Vanessa
this war arc has now opened multiple
battle fronts and in the next few
chapters we can expect to see some truly
epic battles that may cement black
clovers position as a modern Shonen
classic we just said Zenon wrecking
havoc with the Golden Dawn and then
disappearing and going who knows where
now we have Vanek ax and Meggie Kula
attacking the Hart Kingdom and other top
tier mages seem to be attacking in
multiple places at once and we also have
Dante who is potentially the strongest
member of the dark triad attacking the
black Bulls right inside their own
headquarters I have to say that in terms
of hype and excitement this arc has
really been amazing and it has exceeded
my expectations after the big kotodama
fight I honestly didn't know where the
story would go from here I had no idea
how they were going to up the stakes
after such a powerful villain and a
villain who it turns out was responsible
for pretty much all of the major
conflicts in the story thus far
after that arch-villain was defeated I
was afraid that the story would lose its
charm where could they go from here
but I gotta give it to yuki Tabata and
his team they really succeeded in
keeping up the hype raising the stakes
even further and keeping me interested
in the story even after the kotodama
epicness
but let me know what you guys think is
Dante being possessed by the strongest
demon of all the demon king and if so
does this mean that we are about to see
a black bull death in the coming
chapters also how do you think Yami will
fare against Dante does he stand a
chance personally I think that even Yami
will need help from hasta and many of
his other teammates in order to stand a
chance against Dante based on the
information that we have so far feel
free to share your feedback down in the
comments below if you enjoyed this black
clover video and you want us to keep it
going please leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar or you just haven't subscribed
yet please consider subscribing and
hitting that notification bell to turn
on all notifications as I said earlier
if you want to be notified and you don't
want YouTube to bury our videos you
really have to go through the trouble of
clicking the bell and selecting the
option that says all and you can also
hit me up on Twitter and/or Instagram at
anime uproar I want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime out patrons for
supporting our work and making these
videos possible with all the constant
problems on YouTube patron support is
more important than ever thank you guys
so much
first and foremost a special thank you
to our the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above all other clans including in
grata alone Adam the world stealers the
school bus
Tyson Corina acquired respect and Pat a
heffa and I can't forget our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings eldred's fitted ala beat alpha do
Anatoli Cassatt's key on hell Cruz team
Sparky 65 cricket XP Rohan Kapoor
Jessica Maloney Emperor otaku Timothy
Eve Argus Sean dark Joe Stanton JCCC
waka Barrie Gucci and Jessica Calif all
if you enjoy our videos and you think
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see us face cowboys
[Music]